lo que nos piden es que multipliquemos
32.12 sea 32 unidades y 12 centésimas
por punto 5 o sea por 5 décimas y cuando
queremos multiplicar números que tienen
números decimales lo que hacemos es por
un segundo olvidarnos de los números
decimales multiplicar los dos números y
después contar la cantidad de números
que hay a la derecha del punto de cada
uno de los dos números y esta es la
cantidad de números que tienen que haber
a la derecha del punto de nuestro número
final a ver vamos a ver un ejemplo para
que quede muy claro tenemos aquí 32.12 y
lo estamos multiplicando por 0.5
entonces vamos a olvidarnos de que aquí
están estos puntos y vamos a hacer la
multiplicación a ver si nos olvidamos de
los puntos lo que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar 3.212 por 5 así es que
multiplicamos el 5 por el 2 y esto lo
que nos da el 10 ponemos un 0 por acá y
un 1 por acá para recordar que a lo que
nos debe la multiplicación tenemos que
sumarle 1 ok entonces después
multiplicamos el 5 por el 1 y eso nos da
5 pero hay que recordar que le tenemos
que sumar 1 entonces nos queda x 6
después 5 por 2
otra vez 10 ponemos el 0 por acá y el 1
por acá para sumarlo y finalmente 5 por
3 es 15 más el 1 que le tenemos que
sumar eso nos da 16 16 bien entonces
3.212 por 5 nos da 16 mil 60 y
ahora sí ya podemos empezar a considerar
los puntos decimales
a ver cuántos números hay a la derecha
de este punto pues si hay 12 y cuántos
números hay a la derecha de este punto
pues hay otro entonces hay tres números
a la derecha de los puntos y lo que
tenemos que hacer es contar 1 2 3 y
poner el puntito por acá hay un número a
la derecha del punto y este es otro
número a la derecha del punto o sea ya
tenemos 2 y otro número a la derecha de
un punto y entonces tenemos 3 números a
la derecha de un punto y entonces en el
resultado de la multiplicación tenemos
que tener 3 números a la derecha del
punto o sea que el punto tiene que ir
aquí esa es la forma de multiplicar
números decimales entonces como
resultado final de 32 puntos 12 por 0.5
16.06 nos podemos olvidar a este último
cero porque realmente no nos está
aportando ninguna información y bueno
una vez que terminas de hacer una
multiplicación siempre es muy buena idea
ver que el resultado que te quedó tiene
sentido entonces veamos estamos
multiplicando algo que se parece
muchísimo a 32 por 0.5 pero pues hay que
recordar que 0.5 es exactamente igual a
5 entre 10 que ya su vez es igual a un
medio y bueno tomando en cuenta esto
tiene todo el sentido del mundo que
32.12 por punto 5 o sea 16 06 o 16 con 6
centésimas porque al final de cuentas 32
por un medio a cuánto es igual a 16 y
punto 12 por un medio o sea la mitad del
punto 12 la mitad de 12 centésimas es
igual a punto 06 o sea si tenemos 12
centésimas y los
a la mitad pues nos van a quedar seis
centésimas entonces este es el resultado